-Hey, everybody,
the election is two weeks away,
and a lot of eyes
are on Pennsylvania.
It's a battleground state,
and it's important
that everyone gets to vote.
Well, our friend LeBron James
is doing some great work
down there with his
More Than a Vote initiative
to fight voter suppression
and make sure
everyone's vote counts.
But a lot of people say
the ballots in Pennsylvania
are confusing.
So, here to help you
through the process
and make things easier
are Philadelphia's own
The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Unh, unh ♪
-Sorry, sorry, sorry!
Can we do that last part
one more time?
I put the secrecy envelope
in the where?
-Uh, listen.
-Yeah, I got it,
I got it, I got it, I got it.
[ Laughter ]
Last steps?
Tariq Trotter
and The Roots, everybody!
Make a plan!
Go vote!
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody!
♪♪
-♪ This is a ballot ♪
♪ This is not a salad ♪
♪ Yo, if you start wildin' ♪
♪♪